bro you do something you are you know do
something a little edgy
do something deliver a pizza yeah that's
shaped like a uh
illegal symbol for the symbol on it yeah
deliver a pizza somebody did that they
did yes
pepperonis dude i saw them really i saw
it somebody got in trouble oh damn
please look up swastika pizza
please google that dude
yes look at that oh man
and the irony is it's made out of pork
isn't it
so that's a double entendre right yeah
that's bad news
um yeah
that is a bad news pizza little caesar
just fires two workers
you know how it went oh i've talked
about it you know how it went one dude
was like i can't wait for him to pull
this out of the oven and see that i
ruined it and the other guy just must
have pulled it out not even [ __ ]
looked at it just thrown in a box
shipped it
then the other guy's sitting there like
yo what'd you do with that pizza
he's like dude it's out it's all it's
tracking oh
it's trash you're watching like oh [ __ ]
it's at their house dude yeah who are
they
dominoes what the [ __ ] you're like is it
b-r-g or b-e-r-g which one is it
oh man that is a freaking scene
so yeah disaster opening that i'd be so
happy if i got home opened a pizza i'd
be like holy [ __ ] dude the little
caesars are [ __ ] wild now they're
wilding out man
uh look there's the two workers
oh wait no that can't be the two workers
it has to be
but they just put two random could be
the victims
fired up
are we now that we're talking about this
little caesar says we're deeply
disappointed by the actions
but bring up little caesar this guy
looks a little third reiki oh for sure
look at them mussolini the guy
definitely no it's
which no these are the victims
oh these are the vic they receive his
wife misty
i love him i love that people are named
like after kind of like weather like
kind of light climate conditions
misty sunny dusty
so my husband stopped at little caesar's
name dropping for a quick bite
husband brings this someone truly
disappointed yeah
ah
[ __ ]
these aren't funny jokes and shouldn't
be made
it's true they're kind of funny jokes i
mean it's you don't think it's a funny
joke but a squashing on a little
caesar's pizza
it's obviously a funny joke dude it is
funny it's [ __ ] funny yes i agree
it's a fireball
right and this is the owner of little
caesars
holy [ __ ] dude he's got a roman haircut
yeah that is totally that's caesar bro
that's the drawing that's why bring up
the drawing it is
i think that is him
wow
and humor is a risk like i always
the thing that was always funniest to me
was
a telling a humor or being a doing a
humor when you
write when it's not supposed to be done
like the guy's a little caesars yeah
taking chances dude yeah taking a chance
yeah the guy they took they took a
chance man they somewhere he took a
chance dude and they are probably
legends amongst their friends they are
probably
uh truthfully and look never put a
swastika on a pizza right not advocating
that yeah they deserve to be fired yes
that's a good cancel yep there's a good
cancel there yeah because it's dicey
you're using product to push your own
agenda
but those dudes are probably funny yeah
there's no chance those dudes are not
funny yeah that's because they're not
real nazis they're not right they were
real nazis they're not putting swastikas
on pizzas right they're doing other
works they understand how wildly funny
it is
like holy [ __ ]
and here's the crazy they're willing to
risk their careers now
it's so funny i'm sorry the word careers
is awesome there's that little secret
word in there yeah but they're putting
it on the line
they're all in that's a good point like
yo i'm risking my little caesars job
this is gonna be funny yeah
it just blows up it's basically like
german roulette is what it is a little
bit
uh you're right man so then the weird
part is the weird part sorry to keep
cutting off but just
when they got home and seen that tweet
that lady that misty said or whatever
her name was it's like oh [ __ ] she's
pissed
yeah we're in trouble dude
i wonder if they tried like 16 dude i
wonder if they tried to blame it on the
delivery dude i bet they did i'd i'd be
[ __ ] scrambling to blame it on
anybody they probably had to interrogate
them separate be like your boy snitch we
know
my boy would never snitch on the
swastika pizza dude it wasn't us
fight could you find out how old they
were
yeah i think i've looked into this and
actually talked about the question as
well
but they didn't
show the fellas just two employees
who would have thought that that guy's
idea
adolf hitler's
we're talking 19
after world war one he's he's [ __ ]
wounded he's saying his idea
would someday reach the whole way to a
little caesars in ohio
and just [ __ ] someone's day up
in
but this is one thing i think that's
good butterfly flaps its wings type
scenario yeah
just a guy in austria gets denied from
art school
somebody's getting a [ __ ] up pizza in
the future
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one